you brought up Michael Thomas if there's
one team so we have a new Falcons and
it's the Saints which is incredible I've
picked to go to the Super Bowl where you
were a head of the Saints last year have
win in the South before anybody did but
I'm noticing something yeah you are
lower on chimera than most people right
you are lower on mike thomas thomas than
most people yes and you are definitely
lower on Drew Brees than most people
right and it's not because you don't
like the Saints it's because you're so
darn high on Sean Payton yes and what
what I would like you to do for the
people out there and even Michael Thomas
who responds to tweets apparently right
and people that when you don't put them
on the list it's it's because you
believe that Sean Payton puts people in
a position to succeed is that better
than almost any other coach in the NFL
right and if you could explain to people
without even having to look up numbers
yeah what what is it about Sean Payton
that other coaches don't do and what is
it about Sean Payton that truly in your
mind makes him a top five play caller in
the history of the NFL right like you do
you really put him up there with the
bill Walsh's without a doubt do you
really put him up there with like the
great offenses of all time or Coryell
you just name it yeah he's he's
surpassed like he's surpassed all of
them except for maybe okay a Bill Walsh
okay that's that's this really special
guy but other than that then Sean Payton
with all that he's done offensively for
that New Orleans Saints football team
all right so first of all let's just
take what we saw yesterday
okay just think about all the things he
does to give it give as a team an
advantage okay he plays in that game
they go for it on fourth down on the
first drive of the football game four
times four times and but why does that
make him a good coach
well it makes him a good coach because
it's again aggressiveness it keeps them
in control of things they're often
starts to go damn
okay coaches he's got confidence that we
can continue to do that and they were
good play call stream Lee creative play
calls except for the one pitch out when
they think it might get it to except
they just got too close to each other
and Taysom Hill misses it but it's
aggressive play calling like that
keeping a Baltimore Ravens defense out
on the field which is not used to it's
used to get
the feel let's go out over there and
rest so we can be back a hundred percent
yeah kick some butt again you change the
dynamic of the football game right off
the bat with little stuff like that now
let's talk about the taste some he'll
part oh no they've played two outside
road games this year on the first drive
of both of those games he's called
Taysom Hill fake punts okay and they got
first downs both of those times and
that's him so that's him
that's totally head coach stuff head
coach is the guy that makes those plays
and decisions he goes in during the week
and goes what he might ask the special
teams coach on a Monday or Tuesday what
do you think or maybe two or three fake
special teams plays we could get away
with this week how do you think the rest
of the NFL talks about Sean Payton I
think a lot like I do in fact I know
they do
he's a staple for a lot of OU season
football because they want to go what's
the new scream pay what's the new play
action pass he's running you know what's
what did he do on he ran all these
fourth downs let me go see what he did
on these fourth downs to go back and so
I can maybe use one or steal one when I
have a fourth and short but ok it's it's
it's more than even that with Sean
Payton it's the toughness of his
football team this team went from a oh
we're gonna be five five thousand yards
a year with Drew Brees and we're gonna
throw the ball all over the lot too man
Drew's getting up there a little bit I
don't know if he can carry us with 5,000
anymore let's become a power running
team and Smash Mouth football you know
who's one of the best running teams in
football the last two years the New
Orleans Saints they never they never
lose patience with it they run the ball
and just about everybody we're seeing
okay that also seems like he has
complete control of this franchise he
does for the most part yeah I mean it's
him and Mickey Loomis or making player
decisions together
but yeah how can you not trust them
because it's funny because it seems like
you everyone focuses on the Saints that
you underrate right but really what
you're saying is no you're all
underrating Sean Payton of course they
are now again okay so there's that
you know the run game you forget the
play get the play design which is like
we talked about this a few weeks ago
Sean Payton is without a doubt one of
the best run game designers in football
he is either one two or three in the
screen game it's either him McDaniels or
McVeigh and
play-action passes down the field for
shots I would say it's Kyle Shanahan one
and Sean Payton two and then maybe
McVeigh three it's very close there
either way so if we put Sean McVeigh
Kyle Shannon Josh McDaniels
I mean we're gonna throw in Andy Reid
Doug Peterson all these guys in a room
Sean McVeigh and I said which one of you
guys do you all look at and go man they
got some dynamic stuff they're probably
looking at what McVeigh and Peyton yeah
I mean they're all gonna go he does
things in his offense that he likes they
have all their they're all little
strengths but I think Sean Payton really
has no weakness to his overall offensive
game planning let's just talk about
let's just talk about the
record-breaking game for Drew Brees a
few weeks ago yes Peyton Manning's
record I'm not hating on Drew Brees
he's one of the ten best quarterbacks in
the history of football you know maybe I
say he's 12 he's right around there but
you know still incredible which I know
well that a play quarterback but let's
think about how all right so he breaks
the record on a great play design with a
wide open with a wide open who was that
Cameron Meredith on that one no it
wasn't it was who was it the other kid
Trey Quan symmetric ones so trey Quan
Smith for a wide-open 62-yard touchdown
pass where nobody's in the screen the
ball went like 20 yards let alone
earlier in the game to help those yards
out we saw what a Mark Ingram ski 28
yard what down to the one-yard line
screen pass it's always plays like that
and Michael Thomas is a really good
football player but again how can
anybody watch yesterday and go Michael
Thomas is on the level of some of the
other guys that I've put in front of him
I mean he's not like here in a double
move out and up which was called by Sean
Payton in the huddle okay and it was set
up and drew threw the ball perfect but
other than that what was there that
makes everybody go oh wow it's so
dynamic and special after the catch sure
he's just blowing by people deep and
they have to put another guy on him so
it's not about a disrespect for anybody
else Michael Thomas is really good I
just don't think he's one of the 10 best
in football he has a definite role
within that offense and Sean Payton
knows how to use him within that role
that's what he is he's better Marques
Colston that's what he is for them back
shoulder catches work the middle of the
field catch a slant down in the ground
in the video endzone for a touchdown
catch those tough footballs that keep
the drives moving I spit there there's a
lot but yes that's why I look at Sean
Payton I don't know if that was good
enough for you it was perfect how about
a how about an onside kick to start the
second half of a Super Bowl that
nobody's ever done in the history of the
sport how about that I think that's the
part of Sean Payton that all those other
offensive coordinators that I mentioned
I see it sometimes from Sean McVeigh but
Sean Payton has the most guts Sean
Payton is and you said this when we were
talking on OCS a few weeks ago he dials
up the biggest oh crap place on a
regular basis to really catch you yeah
and he has no fear and Sean Payton to me
is a defensive coaches mindset with the
brains of an offensive court and thank
you that's what it feels what do they do
they went into Baltimore yesterday and
said no they said we're Baltimore screw
Baltimore well we'll show you how to run
and play tough football they out
Baltimore Baltimore in Baltimore yeah
nobody does that